...
Donc je crois que c'est un moment de questions et réponses maintenant.
Et j'aimerais que vous sachiez
que je prêche la parole de la manière dont je le fais
pour un but très spécial.
Pour générer la réflexion.
Pour secouer.
Pour que vous pensiez à ces choses.
Qui a une question ?
Je suis content que vous avez énoncé la question de cette manière.
Parce que pertinent, c'est un mot qui est utilisé beaucoup.
Comment on doit faire les choses de manière pertinente.
En fait, la Bible n'utilise jamais ce mot pertinent.
La Bible ne le fait jamais.
Et parfois les gens utilisent ce mot pertinent.
Et ils sont bibliques.
Et je sais ce qu'ils veulent dire.
Mais nous n'avons jamais à rendre la vérité pertinente.
Nous avons besoin de rendre la vérité compréhensible.
Une fois, quelqu'un m'a demandé.
Quelqu'un m'a demandé.
Comment prêcher l'évangile à une tribu à Boira.
Je ne sais pas.
Je prêche l'évangile à des hommes.
À des êtres humains.
Et mon point était celui-ci.
Je n'ai pas besoin de transformer l'évangile.
Juste parce que je parle à une certaine tribu.
J'ai besoin peut-être d'avoir plus d'explications.
Mais je n'ai pas besoin de changer quelque chose.
Pourquoi ?
Peut-être à cause de ma grande vue de l'anthropologie biblique.
Cet homme dans cette tribu éloignée a le même problème que l'homme éduqué à Paris.
Le péché.
La culpabilité.
Sans espoir.
Donc je ne fais juste que prêcher.
Je vous donne un exemple.
Comment cela peut être tout à fait confus et tordu.
J'ai entendu des traducteurs qui disaient.
Il y a des tribus qui n'ont pas la notion d'agneau.
Mais ils ont des concepts de cochon.
Des notions de cochon.
Et la question de ces traducteurs était celle-ci.
Est-ce qu'on devrait dans la Bible changer Jésus en agneau, en cochon ?
Voilà le problème des traducteurs et on voit qu'ils ne sont même pas chrétiens pour certains d'entre eux.
Je lui ai dit, mettez une image d'un agneau tout simplement.
Expliquez simplement qu'est-ce qu'un agneau a cette tribu.
Oui, ça sera peut-être plus difficile.
Mais explique ce que la Bible veut dire.
C'est notre travail d'expliquer la profonde vérité.
Et expliquez cette vérité.
Et peut-être qu'on aura besoin de faire ça d'une façon différente.
Mais le message est toujours le même.
Voyez-vous ?
Toujours.
C'est étudier le texte.
J'ai été au sein des tribus les plus primitives de ce monde.
Et j'ai deux amis, des amis, qui ont vécu dans le lieu le plus primitif du monde.
Et j'ai des amis qui ont même vécu au sein de ces tribus parfois très primitives.
Et ils me disent eux-mêmes, on n'a aucun problème avec la pertinence.
Pour être honnête avec vous.
La notion de pertinence vient même de la culture occidentale des missionnaires.
Qui n'ont aucune confiance dans les Écritures et dans l'Évangile.
La plupart des gens n'ont pas leur confiance dans les Écritures.
Alors ils inventent et ils ajoutent des manières stupides pour annoncer l'Évangile.
Je connais des missionnaires qui vont dans des tribus.
Et ils font ce travail historique.
Ils commencent avec la création.
Et ils continuent.
Et trois, quatre ans plus tard, ils arrivent à l'Évangile.
C'est faux. C'est erroné de faire ça.
Ce n'est pas dans l'Écriture.
Ce n'était pas la pratique de l'apôtre Paul.
C'est juste erroné.
C'est stupide.
Et vous savez ce que j'ai découvert ?
C'est quelque chose de très moderne finalement.
J'ai lu beaucoup de serments de Charles Spurgeon.
Et il parle d'un groupe de missionnaires.
À ses jours.
Qui sont arrivés avec cette idée.
Et ils sont allés à des endroits reculés.
Et au 18e siècle, ils parlaient à ces gens.
Et ils se sont dit, ces gens-là ne peuvent pas comprendre l'Évangile.
Alors on doit construire une base pour qu'ils puissent comprendre.
Alors on va essayer cette approche historique des choses.
Et après un an et demi, deux ans, ils n'avaient aucun succès.
Et ensuite ils sont arrivés au point de se dire, ok, on va juste proclamer l'Évangile.
Et ils ont parlé de la mort du Christ à la place des pécheurs.
Et un des leaders de ce groupe-là,
Un des membres de la tribu a dit, mais pourquoi vous ne nous avez pas dit ça depuis le premier jour ?
C'est la chose la plus importante.
Pourquoi avez-vous attendu ?
Vous savez ce que c'est pour la plupart du temps ?
Votre chair déteste deux choses.
Votre chair déteste étudier la parole de Dieu.
Votre chair déteste cela.
Votre chair déteste la prière d'intercession.
Alors vous allez faire d'autres inventions toutes aussi stupides les unes que les autres.
Et quand vous faites cela, vous êtes comme des enfants qui jouent à la guerre sans armes.
Et je sais que les missionnaires détestent que je dise ce genre de choses.
Et je n'aime pas être détesté.
Ça m'impacte.
Mais ce que je vous dis est vrai.
Je leur ai demandé.
Combien de temps par jour étudies-tu la parole ?
Combien de temps par jour prêches-tu la parole ?
Combien d'heures par jour es-tu impliqué dans la prière d'intercession ?
Combien de temps, à quelle fréquence tu jeûnes ?
Non, ils ont leur propre stratégie.
Vous voyez ?
Nous avons besoin d'être sensibles.
On a besoin d'être sensibles aux cultures.
Mais jamais au détriment de notre mandat et de notre appel.
Au Pérou, par exemple.
À cause de l'œuvre missionnaire depuis plus de 80 ans.
Lorsque je suis arrivé dans les années 80.
Les gens étaient sauvés.
Les gens ont prêché la parole dans la rue.
On prêchait partout.
On allait dans des parcs et on prêchait.
Les gens venaient et écoutaient.
Ils pourraient avoir un concert.
Vous pouvez, pendant l'intermission,
aller sur la plateforme et prêcher parfois.
Parfois, il y avait même des concerts.
Et nous, pendant la petite pause,
on allait sur l'estrade et on prêchait.
Voilà ce qu'il en est.
Mais si je suis ici, à Paris,
honnêtement, on n'a pas exactement le même contexte.
Est-ce que je prêcherais dans la rue ?
Peut-être.
En fait, ce n'est pas peut-être, je le ferais.
Mais la question est comment.
À quoi je dois penser ?
Mais ça ne va jamais changer mon message.
Et ça ne va jamais changer les armes que j'ai pour le combat.
La proclamation,
la prière d'intercession
et une vie de Dieu,
une vie de sainteté.
La prière d'intercession
Parlons juste du fait que cette église était œcuménique.
Il y a des croyants
qui sont des chrétiens authentiques
et je mourrai pour eux
et je les aime
et je reconnaîtrai qu'ils sont croyants.
Mais en même temps,
on parle d'anciens.
On ne peut pas avoir un groupe d'anciens
qui a différentes doctrines.
Parce qu'en fait,
ce que vous êtes en train de communiquer à l'église,
c'est que la vérité n'importe pas.
Ou pire, que personne ne peut comprendre
ce que Dieu a voulu révéler.
Je connais une église
où il y a un ancien qui se lève
et qui prêche sur la persévérance des saints,
la sécurité du croyant.
Et il y a un autre ancien
qui ne croit pas à ça.
Et donc, il y a quelqu'un qui croit
à un truc intermédiaire
entre ces deux choses.
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?
Si les anciens ne peuvent pas trouver d'accord,
alors ils ne devraient peut-être pas être anciens ensemble.
Parce que la confusion que cela peut créer
serait grande.
Surtout lorsque vous parlez d'Ephésiens 4
où on voit qu'une église mûre
a une unité en Christ,
une unité d'esprit.
Elle grandit ensemble.
Mais lorsque les anciens n'ont pas cette unité ensemble,
ça communique juste le fait
que la doctrine et la vérité
ne sont pas d'une grande importance.
Une chose que je veux que vous voyez
qui est très importante,
si nous pensons que la vérité est née avec nous
et que nous mourrons avec la vérité,
nous avons un problème.
Si nous pensons que nous sommes la seule église,
alors normalement,
on a un problème,
habituellement.
L'église dans laquelle vous étiez,
je ne pourrais pas personnellement
être membre d'une église
qui ne pratique pas la discipline biblique.
J'ai même une confession dans notre église
qui dit que si une église
ne pratique pas la discipline biblique,
ce n'est même pas une église.
Mais si je dois quitter cette église,
voilà ce que je ferai.
Je n'irai pas aller parler à tous les membres.
J'irai directement voir les anciens
et leur dire
voilà toutes les raisons
pour lesquelles je quitte cette église.
Et si je peux reconnaître
qu'ils sont des chrétiens authentiques,
j'aimerais partir en paix
avec un respect mutuel,
mais j'ai des convictions.
Alors je partirai.
Vous avez commencé une église.
Dieu s'est toujours servi d'hommes faibles.
Excuse-moi.
Et le Seigneur oeuvre au travers de circonstances
qui ne sont pas...
Qui ne sont pas matures,
mais en parlant des façons de faire
qui ne sont pas...
Merci.
Donc vous n'êtes pas parti de cette église
et vous n'avez pas été ordonné.
Voilà ce que vous devriez faire.
Vous ne devrez pas fermer les portes de votre église.
Vous ne devez pas arrêter votre ministère.
Vous devriez chercher la communion
avec une église similaire à la vôtre.
Avec des anciens matures.
Avec une bonne doctrine.
Qui ont les qualifications requises
de biblique.
Et vous présentez à eux.
Et leur demandez
est-ce que vous pouvez nous aider
à récupérer ça.
Et leur demandez
est-ce que vous pouvez nous aider
à ce que nous traversions,
à ce que la Bible nous demande.
est-ce que vous,
en tant qu'anciens,
vous pouvez surveiller
notre travail ?
Qui n'a peut-être pas commencé
d'une manière
parfaitement biblique.
Mais vous pouvez remédier
à ça maintenant.
Voyez-vous.
Je connais des églises
en Espagne
qui se sont alliées
autour d'un pasteur David
à Barcelone.
Et ces anciens
ont nourri
ces différentes églises.
Voilà, c'est très important.
Donc c'est une église
hispanophone.
Donc ça pourrait être aussi
une église française
avec laquelle vous êtes
en association.
Mais il faut que ça soit
la même doctrine.
Est-ce que vous avez écrit
une confession de foi
pour votre église ?
Oui.
Which ?
La confession de l'Ontario
est en Londres.
La confession de l'Ontario.
Ok.
C'est génial.
Oui.
On peut en savoir quelque chose.
On pourra peut-être en parler
et discuter de ça.
All right.
Une bonne personne
pour vous parler
serait Justin Peters.
Il a la polio.
Et c'est un apologète.
Et c'est quelqu'un
qui débat
et va en confrontation
avec beaucoup
de mouvements charismatiques.
Et qui expose
les mensonges
de ces mouvements.
Voilà ce que nous devrions comprendre.
Voilà.
Je vais vous la mettre
d'une manière rigolote.
Bigfoot.
Yeah.
Yeti.
Le Yeti.
Vous avez déjà entendu
parler du Yeti ?
Le singe blanc.
Parfois,
il y a des programmes télévision
à propos du Yeti.
Et il y a plein d'experts
assis autour de la table.
Et ils parlent
de combien cet animal est grand.
Et comment ils voyagent
en famille.
Comment ils construisent
des huttes.
J'aimerais juste
m'asseoir
dans cette pièce
avec eux.
Et leur demander
est-ce qu'il y a
un d'entre vous
qui a vu ces choses.
Vous dites
toutes ces choses.
Mais est-ce que
l'un d'entre vous
a vu cet animal ?
La plupart des gens
qui nous parlent
des guérisons
massives de personnes.
Est-ce que vous avez
déjà vu un de ces hommes
qui était en fait
un homme biblique ?
Ou qui vit
d'une manière biblique ?
Est-ce que vous avez
déjà vu un de ces hommes
aller à l'hôpital
gratuitement ?
Montrez-moi un homme
qui a cet homme.
Je ne le trouve pas.
Ce don.
Merci.
Je ne le trouve pas.
Est-ce que ça veut dire
pour autant
que Dieu
ne guérit plus ?
Cela veut dire
qu'il y a eu
un changement.
Quelque chose
a changé.
Nous n'avons pas
des hommes
comme Pierre
où l'ombre
guérit
des malades.
si vous dites
c'est parce que
personne n'a la foi
donc ce que vous êtes
en train de dire
c'est que
Dieu en fait
a échoué.
Que Dieu n'a pas été
capable de soutenir
son église
de fournir
des pasteurs
qui croient en lui
suffisamment.
donc il y a quelque chose
qui a fondamentalement
changé.
Mais est-ce que
Dieu guérit
aujourd'hui ?
Évidemment.
L'église
dont je suis membre
est une église
qui prie.
Notre service
du dimanche
commence avec
une heure
de prière
d'intercession.
Il y a des
mercredis soirs
où il y a des
rencontres
juste de prière.
Il y a
des
assemblées
solennelles.
où il y a
des gens
qui ont
des véritables
besoins.
L'église
se rassemble
et parfois
on prie
de deux à
trois heures.
Et dans
ces réunions
j'ai vu
Dieu guérir
des gens.
Pas souvent
mais oui.
Et c'est
quelque chose
d'inexplicable.
Mais voilà
ce que vous
devriez
comprendre.
c'est qu'il y a
un équilibre
entre la
souveraineté
de Dieu
et demander.
Je suis
convaincu
que nous ne
recevons pas
parce que
nous ne
demandons pas.
Mais je suis
aussi convaincu
que ce n'est
pas la volonté
de Dieu
de guérir
tout le monde.
je trouve
ma plus
grande
consolation
dans la
prière du
Seigneur
en fait
à propos
de la
guérison.
Il dit
que votre
nom soit
élevé,
que votre
royaume
vienne,
que votre
volonté
soit faite.
voilà ce
qui
gouverne
toutes
mes prières.
Je vous
donne un
exemple.
Je vis
avec des
douleurs
chroniques.
Il n'y a pas
un seul moment
de ma vie
où je n'ai pas
des douleurs.
quelle est mon
attitude ?
Seigneur,
si au travers
d'une guérison,
ton nom est glorifié,
plus populaire,
plus répandu,
plus honoré,
si au travers
de ma guérison,
ton royaume
s'avance,
si au travers
de ma guérison,
ta volonté
est faite,
accomplie
d'une manière
magnifique,
alors guéris-moi.
Mais,
si au travers
de cette douleur,
de cette maladie,
ton nom
est plus
glorifié,
ton nom
est encore
plus glorifié,
si je deviens
un meilleur
instrument
de ta volonté,
et ça sert
à ton royaume,
alors laisse-moi
tel que je suis.
Voici mon désir.
La douleur
que j'ai.
J'aime
l'athlétisme.
J'aime me battre.
Je ne peux pas.
Ça me bloque le dos
à chaque fois
que quelqu'un me frappe.
Mais combien
cette douleur
m'a aidé
de ne pas être
distrait
de l'évangile.
est-ce que
cette douleur
m'a protégé
de l'immoralité ?
Je ne saurais jamais.
Je ne veux pas savoir.
Mais je le bénis.
Lui et sa sagesse.
voilà ce que je voudrais
que vous voyez.
La faiblesse
n'a jamais handicapé
un homme de Dieu.
Jamais.
parce que lorsque nous sommes
faibles
il est fort.
Disons que quelqu'un
s'approche de moi
avec une fille
mourante
d'un cancer.
Et ils disent
prie pour ma fille.
Qu'est-ce que je vais faire ?
Bien sûr que je vais prier
pour cette fille.
Je vais peut-être
pleurer
et prier
pour cette fille.
Est-ce que je connais
la volonté de Dieu ?
Non.
Et parfois
plusieurs fois
j'ai prié de cette manière.
Seigneur
je ne connais pas
ta volonté.
Mais en tant qu'être humain
je ne veux juste pas
que cette fille meure.
je ne me fais pas
attraper
par tout ça.
Je renouvelle
mon esprit
par la parole de Dieu.
Et pour être honnête
avec vous
je prie
selon aussi
les désirs de mon cœur.
Et je me confie
dans un Dieu
qui est souverain.
Et parfois
des gens peuvent me dire
mais pourquoi tu le veux
qu'il soit guéri ?
Parce que si c'était
ma propre fille
j'aimerais qu'elle soit guérie.
Arrête d'essayer
d'être trop spirituel
avec moi.
On aime les gens.
Mais nous sommes aussi
nous avons aussi
nos affections
dans Dieu
n'est-ce pas ?
Oui.
Bethany Jones qui est la femme de Martin Lloyd-Jones.
Beaucoup pourraient dire que c'est le plus grand expositeur de la Bible du 20e siècle.
Elle dit « Vous ne connaîtrez jamais mon mari en tant qu'expositeur et prédicateur à moins que vous ne le connaissiez dans sa vie de prière. »
Ok.
Et en disant ceci, mon plus grand amour, c'est écrire.
Et parfois, j'étudie et j'écris, ce n'est pas quelque chose de pas commun, mais c'est quelque chose qui arrive régulièrement, mais parfois j'étudie et j'écris pendant 10 heures.
J'ai passé ma vie à étudier les Écritures.
Et je ne suis pas un prêcheur typique.
Peut-être que j'aurais dû être un prédicateur un petit peu plus typique.
Il y a beaucoup de prédicateurs qui passent leur semaine à étudier pour leurs sermons.
Et c'est très important.
Je passe moi ma semaine juste à étudier la Bible.
Par exemple, ce matin,
je lui ai demandé, moi personnellement, quel texte il allait partager ce matin.
Et je lui ai répondu, tu sais, après avoir prié au pupitre, c'est à ce moment-là que je souris.
Parfois, ça se passe de cette manière.
Mais si le pasteur de mon Église me dit de prêcher sur une série d'un Thessaloniciens,
je vais certainement passer beaucoup d'heures dans ma semaine pour étudier sur ces sermons.
Parce que j'aimerais voir votre visage, savoir à qui je prêche ce matin.
Mais parce que j'ai beaucoup trop étudié,
je peux extraire simplement partout dans la Bible et commencer à vous prêcher.
Parce que j'ai étudié tout ça.
Concernant la prière, il y a différents types de prières.
Pour certaines personnes, le seul type de prière qu'ils connaissent, c'est l'intercession.
Ils vont sur leurs genoux et demandent.
Et c'est une partie de la prière.
Mais ce n'est pas tout ce que la prière est.
Il y a le fait de prier avec ses bottes et sans ses bottes.
Prier avec mes bottes, c'est l'intercession.
C'est du travail dur.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose de fun.
C'est comme se battre.
Les gens me disent, je n'aime pas l'intercession.
Et je leur réponds, moi non plus.
Comme un soldat qui n'aime pas aller sur le champ de combat.
Parce qu'on s'approche de Dieu.
On prie pour les nations.
On prie pour les âmes.
Et on dit au Seigneur, je ne peux pas te laisser partir avant que tu fasses quelque chose pour cette nation.
On transpire et c'est fatigant.
Et si c'est tout ce que vous faites,
vous allez avoir un burn-out.
Prier, c'est parfois aussi, ça peut être s'asseoir avec un verre de café le matin.
Et avoir un simple moment de communion avec Dieu.
Avoir un moment de communion avec Dieu et sa parole.
Parler à Dieu.
Avoir du plaisir.
Moi, j'habite dans la forêt, dans les bois.
Donc j'aime prendre la route, faire des promenades.
Juste parler au Seigneur.
Et parfois la nuit, quand je n'arrive pas à dormir.
J'aime aller à la fenêtre, regarder et parler.
Juste parler au Seigneur.
C'est une vie de communion avec Lui.
Il y a des personnes qui disent, moi, vous savez, je n'ai pas de moment spécifique.
Je parle comme ça toute la journée avec le Seigneur.
Je ne crois pas réellement à ça.
Parce que de ce que je lis,
et de ma propre expérience,
on apprend à avoir un moment de communion avec Dieu toute la journée.
par ces moments spécifiques de communion qu'on a mis à part.
J'ai besoin d'être prudent avec mes mots,
parce que je n'ai pas exactement le temps d'expliquer.
Il y a aussi la reconnaissance du besoin.
Et la puissance du Saint-Esprit.
Tout ce que nous faisons est surnaturel.
Je ne suis pas charismatique.
Je suis un baptiste réformé strict.
Mais tout ce que nous faisons est surnaturel.
À chaque fois que je me lève pour prêcher,
je suis comme Ézéchiel.
Je suis dans une vallée avec des ossements desséchés.
Je vous challenge d'aller dans un cimetière à Paris
et essayer de ramener quelqu'un à la vie.
Je vous donne un million de dollars si vous y arrivez.
Je ne l'ai pas.
Je ne l'ai pas besoin.
Parce que vous n'allez pas le faire, tout simplement.
Vous devez reconnaître ça.
Vous passez dans le couloir de votre église.
Et que vous voyez un membre venir vers vous.
Et ce membre a un regard sur son visage.
Il a besoin d'aide.
Il n'y a rien que vous puissiez lui donner.
Vous pensez être sage ?
Vous pensez que vous connaissez tous les textes de la Bible ?
Vous n'avez aucun moyen de pouvoir à leur besoin.
Et ils s'approchent de vous.
Et c'est à ce moment qu'il faut prier, Seigneur.
Remplis-moi de ton esprit.
Remplis-moi de ta sagesse.
Que je puisse penser de manière claire.
Que je puisse avoir des conseils sages.
Vous voyez ?
Tout ce que nous devons faire est impossible.
Aimer notre femme bibliquement, c'est impossible.
C'est aussi surnaturel.
Vous avez besoin de la puissance du Saint-Esprit.
Et voilà ce qui me rend en colère aujourd'hui.
Parce que la plupart des gens aujourd'hui qui parlent du Saint-Esprit disent n'importe quoi au sujet du Saint-Esprit.
Et de l'autre côté, les gens qui veulent être bibliques ne parlent pas des choses du Saint-Esprit.
Mais vous ne pouvez rien faire sans le Saint-Esprit.
Rien.
Il y a un livre que je recommanderais.
Il est écrit par Ian Murray.
Il s'appelle Pentecôte, la Pentecôte aujourd'hui.
C'est le point d'interrogation.
C'est peut-être l'exposition la plus biblique et la plus fidèle sur ce que le Seigneur veut dire à propos du Saint-Esprit.
Pardon.
De la puissance du Saint-Esprit.
J'avais 27 ans.
J'étais jeune.
Et j'étais invité à un cours.
Et il était en train de donner un cours.
Qui deviendrait ensuite ce livre.
Et ma vie a été changée.
J'ai commencé à comprendre.
Et il démontra pas seulement les Écritures, mais la manière dont les réformateurs, les puritains ont compris la puissance du Saint-Esprit.
Nous avons besoin d'être en train de supplier Dieu.
D'une plus grande manifestation de la puissance du Saint-Esprit dans notre vie.
Et cela va se manifester par les fruits du Saint-Esprit.
Il va se manifester dans notre compréhension des Écritures.
Dans la proclamation des Écritures avec puissance.
Et pour que nous puissions parvenir à la réalité d'un Dieu vivant.
Faire des choses par la foi.
Pas des choses stupides des prédicateurs de la foi.
Mais croire Dieu pour faire de grandes choses.
Pour faire des pas de foi.
Basé sur les Écritures.
Pour risquer.
D'une manière biblique.
La prière.
Moi, personnellement, j'ai des problèmes avec le sommeil.
Donc, je suis allé au lit à minuit et demi.
J'ai dormi peut-être à une heure et quart.
Je me suis réveillé à quatre heures.
Et je suis fatigué.
Et la chose la plus sage que je pouvais faire,
c'était de retourner au lit.
C'est la chose la plus biblique que j'aurais pu faire.
Parce que nous avons besoin de dormir.
Mais je ne pouvais pas dormir.
Alors, je devrais peut-être utiliser ce temps pour autre chose.
Et voilà comment j'ai prié, par exemple, pour ce matin.
Et voilà peut-être pourquoi je n'ai pas dormi.
Pour prier.
Mes frères.
La mission est grande.
Et nous ne sommes rien.
Quand je pense à Paris, la ville de Paris.
Je pense à Jericho.
Les murs étaient renfermés, cloisonnés.
Personne ne pouvait rentrer, personne ne pouvait sortir.
Et tu vas briser ces murs avec ton intelligence.
Avec ton exposition parfaite des Écritures.
Non, seulement la puissance du Saint-Esprit peut briser ces murs.
La puissance du Saint-Esprit dans la prédication et dans ta manière de vivre.
Est-ce que vous pouvez me parler d'un seul réveil où le résultat n'a pas été une vie de prière ?
Les gens priaient.
Un des versets les plus tristes de la Bible est probablement dans Luc 18.
Après que Jésus ait donné ce merveilleux, glorieux message où il explique comment le Père répondra aux requêtes.
Les prières persévérantes.
Jésus finit.
Jésus dit et conclut en disant, lorsque le Fils de l'homme reviendra, il ne trouvera aucun de ces hommes qui croira à ça.
Vous voyez ?
La prochaine question.
Oui.
Acte chapitre 1.
Acte 1 au verset 8.
Mais vous recevrez une puissance, celle du Saint-Esprit survenant sur vous.
Et vous serez mes témoins à Jérusalem, dans toute la Judée, dans la Samarie et jusqu'aux extrémités de la terre.
Ça ne dit pas seulement vous serez mes témoins.
Vous serez mes témoins.
Ce n'est pas dit vous témoignerez, c'est dit vous serez mes témoins.
On parle ici du caractère.
On parle des œuvres.
Et on parle de la proclamation.
On parle de ces trois choses.
Et ces trois choses ne peuvent être accomplies que sous la puissance du Saint-Esprit.
Vous voyez ?
Et on peut voir ces choses tout au long des Écritures.
Les fruits du Saint-Esprit.
Pourquoi ce passage est si souvent ignoré ?
Galatians 5.
Parfois j'enseigne sur le mariage.
Et vous pouvez extraire tous ces principes bibliques à propos du mariage.
Et j'enseignais en Russie il y a quelques temps.
21 sermons sur le mariage.
Et au 18e serment, il y a un Russe qui a levé sa main.
Et qui a dit, c'est le 18e serment.
Vous n'avez toujours pas parlé du mariage.
Alors de quoi j'ai parlé ?
Vous avez parlé des fruits du Saint-Esprit.
Écoutez.
Si vous ne connaissez rien à propos du mariage.
Mais si vous êtes un homme qui porte les fruits du Saint-Esprit.
L'amour, la joie, la patience.
La bonté, la fidélité.
Le contrôle de soi-même.
Vous n'aurez aucun problème avec le mariage.
Mais si vous connaissez tous les principes du mariage.
Et que vous ne portez pas les fruits du Saint-Esprit.
Les principes ne servent à rien.
Vous voyez ?
Ce n'est pas étonnant que toutes les exigences à propos d'un ancien sont à propos du caractère.
Sauf une.
Voilà pourquoi on ne peut pas poser les mains sur quelqu'un qui n'a pas ces caractéristiques.
C'est la puissance du Saint-Esprit qui produit ce type de vie en nous.
Il y a la proclamation ensuite.
J'espère que si vous avez prêché, vous voyez la différence.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà prêché et vous sentez que c'est vous qui vous êtes mis là par vous-même ?
Et la meilleure chose que vous avez peut-être à faire, c'est juste de descendre du pupitre.
Mais comme vous le savez, on peut être rassuré que la parole de Dieu ne revient jamais sans avoir produit son effet.
Il y a des fois où j'ai prêché le même message.
Et il y a des gens qui me regardaient aussi froid qu'une pierre.
Et parfois j'ai prêché exactement ce même message.
Et les gens sont brisés en larmes et dans des sanglots.
L'Esprit de Dieu est souverain.
Et nous devons être conscients que c'est l'Esprit de Dieu
qui illumine l'Esprit,
qui régénère les cœurs,
qui apporte la conviction de péché.
Votre exposition doit être correcte.
Mais sans la puissance du Saint-Esprit.
C'est probablement la plus grande contribution de Jean Calvin pour l'humanité, pour le christianisme.
Comment quelqu'un peut arriver à la compréhension que l'Évangile est vrai ?
Comment cela se passe ?
On parle avec l'épistémologie, là, on parle de l'épistémologie.
Comment ça marche ?
Je vous donne un exemple.
Il y a un homme que je connaissais dans la montagne du Pérou.
Il était dans un village où il y avait un mix entre le paganisme et le catholicisme.
Et il y a un homme qui est allé là-bas et qui a prêché l'Évangile toute la journée.
Et cet homme a cru.
Un simple prêcheur est allé là-bas et a enseigné la bonne nouvelle.
Et cet homme dans ce village a cru, tout simplement.
La ville, le petit village, on a entendu parler de cette histoire.
Ils se sont rassemblés.
Ils l'ont tapé, frappé avec des cannes.
Et ils ont menacé les enfants aussi.
Et ils ont mis de l'huile brûlante.
Mais il ne s'est pas retiré.
Il me disait non, Christ est suffisant.
Non, Christ est suffisant.
Il n'avait même pas d'éducation, cet homme-là.
Jésus est vivant.
Le salut n'est pas par les œuvres.
Ce n'est pas au travers de l'Église.
Et ils étaient sur le point de le tuer.
Et il n'a toujours pas renié sa foi.
Comment est-ce possible ?
Il est prêt à mourir pour ça.
Après avoir écouté 35 minutes de prédication,
d'un homme qu'il ne connaissait même pas,
il veut maintenant mourir pour cette cause.
Il n'a pas lu de livre sur l'apologétique.
Il ne connaît aucune chose sur les preuves historiques de la résurrection.
Il ne sait même pas où est Jérusalem.
Mais il veut mourir pour cette cause.
Comment est-ce possible ?
Parce que le Saint-Esprit a régénéré son cœur,
a illuminé son esprit,
et a testifié que la parole de Dieu était dans son cœur.
Et voilà comment un Parisien peut être sauvé.
Un Parisien super éducé, super culturel,
c'est comme il peut être sauvé.
Voilà comment un Parisien très éduqué peut être sauvé.
Il y a une histoire à propos de Martin Lloyd-Jones,
qu'il prêche de son pupitre avec d'autres académiciens,
qui était un athée et s'est converti.
Et l'académicien a commencé à parler d'abord.
Et cet académicien disait,
comment on doit évangéliser aux autres académiciens,
et combien on a besoin d'académiciens pour atteindre d'autres académiciens.
On a besoin d'académiciens pour toucher d'autres académiciens.
Et après qu'il est fini,
Martin Lloyd-Jones arrive.
Il dit, j'apprécie beaucoup mon frère,
mais tout ce qu'il a dit était faux.
Et il dit, Wesley était quelqu'un de très éduqué.
Et Dieu l'a envoyé auprès de mineurs de charbon,
et de fermiers.
Et Dieu a pris Muddy.
Et même nous, en tant qu'Américains,
on pensait qu'il ne parlait pas bien.
Et Dieu a pris cet homme qui ne parlait pas bien anglais
vers les aristocrates de Londres.
Et au travers de lui,
beaucoup d'hommes sont parvenus à Christ.
Ne voyez-vous pas ?
Dans la Bible,
Dieu fait toujours les choses de cette manière.
C'est exactement le but de 1 Corinthiens 1 et 2.
que celui qui se glorifie
se glorifie en Dieu.
Parce que la puissance vient de l'Évangile.
Et pas dans l'intelligence du prédicateur.
Nous avons besoin de chercher,
être clair.
Mais vous avez besoin d'être très prudent.
Regardez à l'histoire.
Oui, Dieu a élevé de grands prédicateurs.
Mais j'ai trouvé ça incroyable.
Spurgeon a prédicé à beaucoup de pauvres.
Ils ont lu son truc.
Les éleveurs de bois,
les gens non-éducés,
ils ont lu son truc.
Et ils ont compris les ouvrages de Spurgeon.
Ils ont compris l'Évangile.
Et pourtant, il y a beaucoup de gens
qui vont dans des séminaires aujourd'hui
qui ont du mal à comprendre Spurgeon.
Spurgeon était un homme de Dieu
utilisé par Dieu
pour annoncer la parole de Dieu
pendant un temps très libéral
où il y avait le libéralisme.
Et Dieu a béni son ministère
parce qu'il était amoureux de la parole.
Il faisait confiance à la parole seulement.
Martin Lloyd-Jones, la même chose.
Vous voyez ?
C'est la parole, la parole.
Le Saint-Esprit m'aide.
Aide-moi.
Paul, Colossiens 4,
vous voyez ça aussi.
Priez pour moi.
Que Dieu ouvre une porte
pour que j'annonce
l'Évangile
de manière
la plus claire qu'il soit.
la pratique de la parole.
J'espère que vous filmez.
Je vais vous dire ce que je crois
personnellement fermement.
On peut souvent séparer deux groupes.
Il y a les continuationnistes
et les cessationnistes.
et je me base
dans le camp des cessationnistes.
mais je dis aux gens
qu'il n'y a pas besoin
de faire un tel débat.
Tout ce que nous avons besoin
de faire,
c'est de définir
bibliquement
quels sont ces dons.
Je ne crois pas
que le parler en langue
eût été
une langue non phonétique,
non syllabique.
C'était un vrai langage phonétique.
C'est un langage
que les gens ne connaissaient pas.
donc c'était quelque chose
qui était validé par cela.
Si je me tiens ici
et que je dis cela,
je pense qu'elle a écrit
un Honda,
un Honda.
Comment est-ce validé ?
Comment ce qu'il vient de dire
peut être validé ?
Comment quelqu'un peut penser
que c'est un miracle
ce qu'il vient de dire ?
Ou je commence
à babler ?
Ou je dis juste
des mots,
des voyelles ?
Qu'est-ce que ça fait ?
Rien.
Si d'un coup,
je venais à parler
un français impeccable,
il y a des choses
que vous ne voyez pas
tous les jours.
Et alors,
il y aurait une grande crainte
dans cette place
si tel était le cas.
Voilà ce que je crois
être le don des langues.
Et quand les gens
viennent vers moi
et me disent
qu'ils parlent en langues,
je leur demande
quelle langue ?
Et quand les gens
viennent vers moi
et me disent
je parle en langue,
je leur demande
quelle langue ?
Quel langage ?
Et en 35 ans
personne n'était capable
de dire
qu'ils parlent
en langue.
Et en 35 ans
d'expérience,
personne n'était capable
de venir me voir
et de dire
qu'ils parlaient
une autre langue.
Et je sais
qu'il y a
1 Corinthians 14
qui parle
de quelque chose
et je sais
qu'il y a
certaines personnes
et de très bonnes personnes
qui pensent
qu'un Corinthien 14
parle d'autre chose
et je les aime
mais je pense
qu'ils ont tort.
Voilà ce que je crois.
Quand on regarde
à Actes chapitre 2
particulièrement
le verset 16
du verset 16
au verset 21
parfois on doit rire
de nous-mêmes
ou même nous critiquer
et je dis parfois
à mes frères réformés
vous savez quoi ?
à chaque fois
que je nous entends
parler et prêcher
de Actes
au chapitre 2
on parle à chaque fois
de ce que ça ne veut pas dire
mais qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ?
à chaque fois
que quelqu'un prêche dessus ?
est-ce que ça ne veut rien dire
pour nous aujourd'hui ?
est-ce que c'est quelque chose
simplement pour l'ère apostolique ?
voilà pourquoi je vous recommanderais
vraiment le livre
de Ian Murray
la Pentecôte aujourd'hui
juste rapidement
regardons
à certaines choses
au chapitre 2 verset 16
mais c'est ce qui a été dit
par le prophète Joël
il dit
dans les derniers jours
les derniers jours
quand ont-ils commencé ?
il y a 2000 ans
il est en train de citer
le temps du Messie est arrivé
son royaume n'est pas encore arrivé
à sa pleine consommation
il y a encore beaucoup de choses à venir
mais il n'y a aucun doute
que nous sommes déjà
dans les derniers jours
et c'est très important
de comprendre ça
voici une promesse
de la nouvelle alliance
voilà ce qu'il va arriver
lors de la nouvelle alliance
et ce n'est pas seulement
pour le temps apostolique
mais c'est pour tous
les derniers jours
tous ces derniers jours
lorsqu'on parle des promesses
du Nouveau Testament
j'aimerais diriger votre attention
vers une en particulier
Jérémie 31
versets 33 et 34
Mais voici l'alliance
que je conclurai
avec la maison d'Israël
après ces jours-là
oracle de l'éternel
je mettrai ma loi
au-dedans d'eux
je l'écrirai sur leur cœur
je serai leur Dieu
et ils seront mon peuple
celui-ci n'enseignera plus
son prochain
ni celui-là son frère
en disant
connaissez l'éternel
car tous me connaîtront
depuis le plus petit d'entre eux
jusqu'au plus grand
car je pardonnerai leur faute
et je ne me souviendrai plus
de leur péché
si on avait le temps
on serait allé dans
Ézéchiel 36
je suis sûr que vous le connaissez
où il retire le cœur de pierre
pour y mettre un cœur de chair
quelle est la grande promesse
annoncée par Jérémie ici ?
si vous résumez
voilà ce que ces promesses seraient
la connaissance de Dieu
dans la nouvelle alliance
il y aura une connaissance incroyable
de Dieu
et on voit ça accompli n'est-ce pas ?
pensez simplement
je connais des gens
dans la jungle profonde du Pérou
qui comprennent
l'expiation bien mieux
que des saints
de l'Ancien Testament
des femmes
qui ne savent même pas lire
et qui comprennent
que leurs péchés
ont été pardonnés
et qui comprennent
que cela a été accompli
au travers de la mort
et de la résurrection
du fils de Dieu
donc lorsqu'on regarde
ces passages
vous devez croire
à ces passages
mais non seulement
vous devez y croire
mais vous devez y répondre
à ces promesses
la parole de Dieu
vous a été ouverte
l'esprit de Dieu
vous a été donné
il n'y a aucune limitation
dans ce que vous pourrez connaître
à propos de Dieu
dans sa volonté
si vous avez un problème
dans l'église
qu'est-ce que vous faites ?
allez à la parole de Dieu
il va vous donner
la connaissance
dans la nouvelle alliance
nous allons avoir
une connaissance abondante
oui nous avons besoin
d'aller chercher
des conseillers
nous avons besoin
de comparer
nos différentes interprétations
pas parce que la Bible
est faillible
mais parce que
nos interprétations
peuvent l'être
mais cette promesse
annonce
une connaissance
débordante
de Dieu
le voyez-vous ?
voilà ce qui a été promis
concernant
la nouvelle alliance
donc pour tous les problèmes
que j'ai
dès que j'ai besoin
de savoir
voilà ce qui m'a été promis
j'ai partagé ça
la dernière nuit
avec des anciens
laissez-moi vous partager
vous connaissez
des athlètes olympiques
lorsque je les regarde
j'ai l'impression
d'être un sous-humain
vous voyez ce qu'ils font
c'est incroyable
littéralement
mais pensez-y
ils ont
disons 21 ans
ils ont fait ça
depuis qu'ils ont 6 ans
quand tous les enfants
étaient en train de dormir
eux se levaient
lorsque tous les autres enfants
étaient en train de jouer
eux ils s'entraînaient
lorsque tous les enfants
mangeaient des bonbons
eux ils mangeaient
de la salade
ils ont dévoué
toute leur vie
pour faire une seule chose
peut-être que je ne suis pas né
avec leur talent
peut-être pas du tout
mais je serais tellement plus
que ce que je suis
aujourd'hui
si j'avais eu
le même dévouement
dans ma vie
c'est la même chose
je n'ai pas le don
de Charles Spurgeon
ou je n'ai pas les dons
de Martin Lloyd-Jones
mais combien plus
je serais plus
que ce que je suis
aujourd'hui
si j'avais étudié
comme eux
si je m'étais dévoué
à la tueur
de connaître
Dieu's Word
si je m'étais dévoué
entièrement
à l'unique tâche
de connaître Dieu
voyez-vous
la seule limite
dans notre connaissance
de Dieu
c'est nous
c'est votre désir
de
la façon dont vous
mesurez l'importance
de connaître Dieu
donc dans Jérémie
nous avons la promesse
de connaître Dieu
et ça inclut connaître sa volonté
et quand on arrive à Actes
maintenant
qui cite Joël
c'est une promesse similaire
j'aimerais que vous regardiez
à quelque chose
il parle des prophéties
des visions
des songes
des rêves
laissez-moi vous poser une question
lorsque Joël a reçu
cette révélation
vous pensez qu'il était
émerveillé ?
je pense oui
vous pensez qu'il était
émerveillé à cela ?
ah ça va être trop bien
un temps va arriver
où le peuple de Dieu
ils vont avoir des visions
est-ce que vous pensez vraiment
que c'est ça
qui émerveillait Joël ?
ils vont avoir plein de visions
vous pensez vraiment
que c'est ça
dont Joël s'émerveillait ?
ou est-ce qu'il était émerveillé
à propos de ceci ?
un temps va arriver
dans cette nouvelle alliance
où les croyants auront la capacité
de connaître et de parler
sur la parole de Dieu
lorsqu'il parle des prophéties
des visions et des songes
il utilise un langage de prophète
mais Joël ne s'émerveille pas
à propos du fait que
ces gens-là vont voir
des choses un peu mystiques
il est en train de dire
exactement la même chose
que Jérémie
ils vont avoir une connaissance
intense de la volonté
mais Joël voit même plus loin
et pas seulement ça
l'Esprit de Dieu
sera répandu sur leur cœur
la puissance du Saint-Esprit
puissamment répandue
sur la vie
pour vivre au-delà
de ce qu'un homme charnel
pourrait vivre
pour qu'il puisse être capable
de refléter la gloire de Dieu
pour comprendre
pour être capable
de comprendre la parole de Dieu
de vivre
et de se conformer
ils attendent tous
ce moment-là
les prophètes
ils ne sont pas
comme des petits enfants
qui veulent
qui s'attendent
à voir une vision
ce sont des gens matures
et ils ont la gloire
et je me glorifie
dans cela
donc peu importe
ce que j'ai à faire
j'ai la connaissance
suffisante pour le faire
et peu importe
ce que je vais avoir à faire
et il y a la puissance
pour le faire
pour l'accomplir
donc comment il répond
de cette manière
en regardant les écritures
et en priant
en priant
pour plus d'intervention
de la vie de l'esprit
dans ma vie
et dans mon ministère
une autre chose
qui est associée à cela
quelque chose
qui est en train
de faire effondrer
tout le mouvement
réformé aux Etats-Unis
j'avais un grand espoir
pour ce mouvement
mais cet espoir-là
a disparu
c'est cette idée
de prophétiser
avoir le don
de prophétie
mais ils ne comprennent
même pas
ce qu'ils sont en train
de dire
dans le livre
d'Ephésiens
il nous dit
que Dieu a donné
à l'église
des apôtres
des prophètes
des évangélistes
des pasteurs
des enseignants
dans le même livre
Ephésiens 2
il nous est dit
que la fondation
de l'église
ce sont les apôtres
et les prophètes
et il y a un problème
ici
parce qu'il nous est dit
dans 1 Corinthiens 3
que Jésus
est la seule fondation
donc comment Jésus
peut être la fondation
et aussi les apôtres
et les prophètes
en fait il est dit
que les apôtres
et les prophètes
sont la fondation
et que Jésus
est la pierre angulaire
mais les apôtres
et les prophètes
ne sont pas
en eux-mêmes
la fondation
Christ l'est
mais c'est au travers
des enseignements
des apôtres
et des prophètes
que nous connaissons
qui Christ est
leurs enseignements
sont fondamentaux
ils décrivent
leurs enseignements
ont décrit
les fondations
de l'église
les apôtres
et les prophètes
donc plusieurs personnes
vont dire
on a ces 5 types
de ministères
on a des apôtres
dans nos églises
on a des prophètes
on a des évangélistes
des pasteurs
des enseignants
alors que vous
dans votre église
vous en avez seulement 3
vous n'avez que 3 ministères
dans votre église
non en fait
j'en ai 5 moi aussi
dans mon église
partout où je vais
j'ai les apôtres
et les prophètes
ils sont juste là
j'ai la parole
sûre et certaine
des apôtres
et des prophètes
dans ce livre
je n'ai pas besoin
d'aller à Jérusalem
et de parler à Pierre
je n'ai pas besoin
de voyager en Europe
pour trouver Paul
je les ai ici
un prophète
du Nouveau Testament
c'était un ministère
d'une révélation particulière
quelle est la différence
entre les apôtres
et les prophètes
les apôtres
étaient super
ecclésiastiques
à propos de l'église
ils étaient identifiés
très clairement
ils étaient douze
voilà les apôtres
lorsqu'ils parlaient
c'était inspiré
lorsqu'ils écrivaient
cela était inspiré
vous voyez
qui étaient les prophètes
ils ont parlé
de messages inspirés
quelle est la différence
il n'est jamais dit
tester un des vrais
apôtres
ce n'est jamais écrit
dans la Bible
tester Pierre
ou tester Paul
mais il dit
tester les prophètes
comment savons-nous
que cette personne
était en train de parler
sous l'inspiration de Dieu
seulement selon
le prisme
qu'il était en train
d'enseigner
selon les enseignements
des apôtres
nous avons des gens
qui enseignent
même au sein
des mouvements
jeunes réformés
qui ont laissé
laissé court
à la prophétie
et c'est la lunacité
vous savez
juste
se passer
à quelqu'un
et la première chose
qui rentre
dans votre tête
et d'aller
ils vont parfois
aller voir des gens
et leur dire
la première chose
qui est à leur esprit
est-ce que les écureuils
les camions
et les sandwiches
te disent quelque chose
voilà les genres
de questions
que ces gens
aux prophéties
disent
et moi je leur répondrais
oui oui
ça veut dire quelque chose
pour moi
les camions
ça veut dire que tu es
fou
et que je dois fuir
loin de toi
c'est pas ça
une prophétie
et peut-être que même
dans vos églises
vous pouvez dire
que les prophètes
peuvent être dans l'erreur
parce que dans un Corinthien
il est dit
de juger les prophètes
alors que dans
l'Ancien Testament
il était dit
de lapider
les prophètes
qui étaient dans l'erreur
et dans le Nouveau Testament
il n'est pas dit
il n'est pas dit ça
alors c'est un différent
type de prophète
non non non
dans l'Ancien Testament
il lapidait
les faux prophètes
parce que c'était
un grand crime
de mal représenter Dieu
laissez-moi vous dire
quelque chose
si vous vous tenez debout
et que vous dites
voici ce que dit
Dieu
aujourd'hui
en tant que prophète
Nouveau Testament
et si vous avez tort
c'est un péché
tout aussi grand
tout aussi vil
vous êtes en train
de mal représenter
Dieu
alors vous pouvez dire
oui mais dans
l'Ancien Testament
on leur dit
de les lapider
maintenant
on leur dit
de les juger
simplement
oui
mais vous savez
ce qu'il est écrit
aussi dans l'Ancien Testament
si un homme et une femme
commettent un adultère
qu'est-ce que vous êtes
censés faire
lapider les
si un homme et une femme
dans l'église
commettent un adultère
qu'est-ce que vous devez faire
vous devez les
absoudre
vous avez besoin
de les reprendre
de les corriger
et s'ils sont toujours
impénitents
qu'est-ce que vous devez faire
vous avez besoin
de les discipliner
et de les laisser
à Satan
en dehors de l'église
est-ce que Dieu déteste
moins l'adultère
aujourd'hui
qu'il le détestait
dans l'Ancien Testament
non
il le déteste
tout autant
j'ai entendu un homme
parler des prophètes
aujourd'hui
de leur mouvement
et il dit ça
en rigolant
presque 85%
des prophéties
sont fausses
je lui ai dit
mais tu n'as
aucune crainte
de Dieu
c'est exactement
la même chose
et si vous vous tenez debout
et que vous dites
voici ce que dit
l'éternel
j'ai une nouvelle révélation
tu es complètement
en dehors
de l'orthodoxie chrétienne
et si vous êtes
dans une église
vous serez discipliné
jusqu'à ce que vous parveniez
à la repentance
si vous êtes un petit garçon
mais que vous voulez
devenir un soldat
vous pouvez faire ça
vous avez juste besoin
de changer le contexte
personne n'a de balle
personne n'a de vrai couteau
alors vous courez
dans les champs
et vous faites semblant
d'être un soldat
voilà ce que ces gens
sont en train de faire
ils font semblant
mais avec leur révélation
non bibliques
ils causent de gros problèmes
aux gens
je ne vais pas aller
voir quelqu'un à Paris
et lui dire ceci
les croissants
les sandwichs
est-ce que ça signifie
quelque chose pour toi
non je ne vais pas faire ça
même si ça apparaît
dans mon esprit
comment pouvez-vous être à Paris
et ne pas avoir le mot croissant
dans l'esprit
vous savez quelles questions
je pourrais leur poser
excusez-moi
as-tu réellement compris
ce qu'est le christianisme
et est-ce que tu me donnerais
cinq minutes
pour que je te l'explique
ce que vous voyez
ne vous faites pas attraper
par ce genre de mouvement
parce que ça ne va pas
vous donner de la puissance
pour votre ministère à Paris
ça va juste vous dénuer
de toute votre puissance
regardez simplement
aux gens
qui ont changé le monde
c'était simplement
des hommes de parole
c'était des hommes de prière
des hommes de conviction
et des hommes
qui étaient prêts à souffrir
je suis désolé de vous dire
mais vous n'allez pas
affecter Paris
sans souffrance
je ne suis pas
je suis pas
comme
j'étais dans un pays musulman
il y a quelques années
et un des missionnaires
de ce pays
je lui ai dit
vous savez tous ces missionnaires américains
qui sont ici
ils viennent avec des professions
ce genre de choses
est-ce que les autorités du pays
ont une quelconque idée
de ce qu'ils sont en train de faire
et vous savez ce qu'il m'a répondu
et c'est quelqu'un qui a souffert
pour l'évangile
il me dit
mais vous savez
les autorités musulmanes
savent exactement
ce qu'ils sont en train de faire
ces missionnaires américains
alors pourquoi les autorités
les laissent ?
ils s'en fichent
les autorités
parce qu'ils savent très bien
qu'ils sont beaucoup trop lâches
pour faire quelque chose
bien sûr ce n'est pas
tous les missionnaires
mais vous avez compris l'idée
donc vous pouvez écrire à la maison
en code
en faisant croire
que vous êtes persécuté
alors que tout ce que vous faites
c'est partir en promenade
c'est vous cacher
tout le monde peut le faire
parce que ça fait peur
d'aller là-bas
parce que vous savez
vous ne serez pas haï
à cause de votre christianisme
vous serez haï
parce que vous serez jugé
comme un homme haineux
pour être un homme qui juge
pour être un homme qui n'aime pas
vous voyez
les chrétiens ne sont pas persécutés
parce qu'ils sont chrétiens
ils vont vous diffamer
ils vont vous frapper
et vous serez persécutés
à cause des choses
que vous détestez vous-même
mais voilà ce que ça veut dire
être un chrétien
bienvenue au ministère